for decades Bedouins have been on the
Move looking for grazing land water and
better living conditions in the occupied
West Bank they're moving for safety
reasons more than 30 families from the
insomnia community near Ramallah are
packing up their belongings and leaving
the place they've called home for 40
years
is the increase in Israeli subtler
attacks is making it impossible for him
and his family to stay
my children are scared they get
nightmares about settlers if we get hurt
is it worth it land is precious but it's
not more important than the lives of my
children if I try to defend myself I'll
be hurt and if I don't I'll be losing as
well
illegal Israeli settlements and outposts
are surrounding the community
settlers have become more and more
violent towards Palestinians
the Israeli police used to come when we
call and complain settlers used to leave
but now it's a different story they call
the settlers and threatened to come but
they don't so the settlers end up
staying attacking us and sealing our
herds
the Israeli military has issued
demolition orders for their homes some
of which are funded by the European
Union
this video shows what the community
looked like last year
200 Palestinians lived here with their
herds now
they have all left
it took Israeli settlers only a few
hours to move in
they prevented our team from filming and
ordered us to leave then threatened and
chased us away for a few kilometers
Palestinians call this Israeli policy
silent transfer meant to force
Palestinians of their land and bring in
Settlers instead
this transfer of citizens is considered
illegal under international law you can
see how the settlers and material
Administration works together the
settlers are building The Outpost but
the administration is issuing the
demolition orders and demolishing and
shrinking the ability of these
communities to exist altogether no water
no electricity no construction
now the community is trying to start
over
some have moved to alumraier a village
about six kilometers away they say
they're here seeking a safer place for
their families with the rising number of
settler attacks even that might not be
guaranteed
foreign the occupied West Bank